so meine Damen und Herren gestern Abend
gab es wohl ordentlich Zoff im
ampelkoalitionsausschuss und der neue
Streit ist der alte Verkehrsminister
Volker Wissing will immer noch schnell
Neubau von Autobahn obwohl der Verkehr
sein Resort ja jetzt schon sämtliche
Klimaziele reißt ist ja so gut in der
Frage haben die Grünen gestern abend
also wo meine rote Linie gezogen kein
weiterer Kuhhandel wahrscheinlich auch
weil der letzte Kuhhandel an der jungen
grünen Basis eher übel genommen wurde
ich sage nur lützerath das grüne
trauma-lützerat diese Bilder tausende
klimaaktivisten überwiegen friedlich
plus leider auch ein paar hundert
gewaltbereitet und dabei hat das doch
alles so fröhlich angefangen
[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen zu wetten dass
lützrad bleibt
ach mensch leider verloren Wettkönig
wurde stattdessen der Junge Philosophie
Student Robert mit seiner mega Bagger
Wette ja
es gewinnt eigentlich immer die
baggerbette seit dieser Woche ist auch
die strafrechtliche Bilanz von lützerath
etwas klarer es kam zu rund 500
Strafanzeigen unter anderem wegen
Landfriedensbruch oder Körperverletzung
und gegen fünf Polizisten wird auch
ermittelt gleichzeitig haben wir
festgestellt gab es aber auch Szenen die
waren regelrecht rührend also die Person
z.B voll nett auf der anderen Seite sind
Polizist auch eine Lohnabhängige vom
kapitalistischen System und deswegen
habe ich auch nichts gegen Polizistinnen
oder so genau
all Cops a Lohnabhängige vom
kapitalistischen System aber voll nett
sagt das Möhrchen eine von den vom Mund
innen süß aber na komm
ich will hier nichts von niedlichen
natürlich gab es in Lutzerath auch sehr
hässliche szenen wie diese hier
[Musik]
drei Polizisten mit Tinnitus im
Krankenhaus vielen Dank auch ja weil
sich jeder in Deutschland einfach so
eine entsicherte Geige kaufen kann
warum sind geigenfrei verkäuflich bei
dieser Räumung wurde aber nicht nur ein
Dorf untergeflügt sondern auch der
Glaube vieler klimaaktivisten an die
Grünen nutzerath ist vielleicht heißt es
jetzt sowas wie der Hartz iv-moment der
Ökos wenn es doof läuft die eigene
Jugend ist stinksauer weil die Partei
diesen Deal mit RWE ausgehandelt hat sie
weg dafür Kohleausstieg schon 2013 und
dann sind schon ganz ulkig wenn grüne
Bundestagsabgeordnete in lützerath gegen
Gesetze demonstrieren die sie selber mit
beschlossen haben also Demo gegen sich
selber da stellen sich Fragen nutzerat
darf weggebaggert werden das kann man ja
richtig oder falsch finden aber Fakt ist
das hat ein grüner Minister ausgehandelt
das wurde
dort ausgehandelt aber ich finde es
immer viel zu einfach
nur auf die Grünen rauf zu hauen weil
wir haben einen gesamtes Problem
finde es viel zu einfach
mir Fragen zu stellen
bei denen ich scheiße aussehe
dein Eichhörnchen
und dann ist sie weggelaufen
ja so standen also innerlich zerrissene
grüne Abgeordnete an der Abbruchkante
von lützerath mit demo-schildern wie
lützi muss bleiben also theoretisch aber
wir verstehen natürlich total dass man
Kompromisse machen muss in einer
Koalition und es gibt ja auch Gutachten
die die Zerstörung erlauben lest die
doch einfach schön eure grünen zwinker
Smiley
langes Plakat und immer klar kann man
den Frust der Aktivisten nachvollziehen
denn lützerat ist eben doch viel mehr
als ein Symbol wenn die Kohle da
verbrannt wird dann kann Deutschland
sich von seinen Klimazielen offiziell
verabschieden da ist so es ist so wir
planen im Moment doppelt so viel CO2 zu
imitieren wie wir uns für das Erreichen
des 1,5 Grad Ziels gerade noch leisten
können und trotzdem sagen viele Menschen
uh die Nerven diese Aktivisten mit ihrem
Weltuntergangs Gerede die Rotz gehören
wollen ernsthaft den Planeten retten nur
weil sie noch ein paar Jahre mehr auf
der Uhr haben als ich ja dass die
Stimmung deshalb freuen wir Medien uns
ja über alles was man den kleinen
moraler posten um die Ohren hauen kann
nicht mit einer Jute sondern einer
klimafeindlichen Plastiktasche verlassen
die beiden Männer den Tunnel indem sie
sich tagelang versteckt hatten
schick die Scharfschützen rein das
Schwein hat eine Plastiktasche
ja es gibt da offensichtlich gerade so
eine Art mediale Agenda den
klimaaktivismus an sich zu
diskreditieren es ist unglaublich was da
täglich enthüllt wird in der BILD
alleine über diese Luisa Neubauer so wie
hier jeden Tag Schlagzeilen wie Demos
Gewalt und Glamour Luisa Neubauers
perfide per Masche ein Schocker nach dem
nächsten sie kommt aus guter Familie
schau mal eine Frechheit
sie hat einen Freund bei der ARD
und dann lässt sich die faule Prinzessin
in lützelrat auch noch rumtragen von
Staatsdienern immer ein klimaneutral ich
bin gespannt ich bin gespannt wie ein
Flitzebogen was Bild TV noch alles
enthüllt über die feine Dame
Luisa Neubauer ist unglaublich reich
ihre Familie besitzt Immobilien ein
Rechercheteam von bild-tv hat jetzt
enthüllt in ihrem Nachnamen steckt das
Wort Neubau sie kämpft gegen Emissionen
aber ihre Familie der Ring Smart
zigaretten-clan hat jahrzehntelang das
ganze Land zugewandt das Fräulein ist
gegen CO2 Mark ist aber gerne in ihrem
Champagner den sie zur Tarnung in
Wasserflaschen umfüllt die öko-amazone
täuscht uns alle sie hat wunderschöne
Haare das heißt sie benutzt heimlich
Shampoo wahrscheinlich sogar beim
Duschen und die größte Frechheit ihren
klimapodcast nennt Lügen Luisa 1,5 Grad
aber ihre eigene Körpertemperatur
beträgt 37
[Musik]
das Lügengebäude der Luisa Neubauer
bröselt in sich zusammen wir haben
stellen fest sind wirklich harte Zeiten
für die Grünen entfremdet von der
eigenen Basis und dann müssen Sie auch
noch in Berlin mit der FDP regieren und
den Liberalen die die Schwächephase der
Öko-Partei natürlich gnadenlos auskosten
ja im Moment will man echt kein grüner
Abgeordneter sein was die alles
einstecken müssen in der Ampel Martin
Klempner und z.B Martin klemmt no sitzt
für die Grünen im Verkehrsausschuss
schon auf dem Weg ins Büro muss er sich
mit den ersten FDP Kollegen rum ärgern
allerdings Wagen hey Rene schön dass ich
euch treffe so sag mal habt ihr schon
die neue Studie zum Tempolimit gelesen
doch viel mehr CO2 als gedacht echt hört
sich voll interessant an
wir sehen uns später im Ausschuss
ja es ist eine schwierige Zeit gerade
die Kollegen von der FDP die finanziert
total lustig dass wir Grünen wegen lützi
so ein Druck kriegen das wird mir jetzt
auch ständig reingerieben ist teilweise
auch um bisschen kindisch aber
da stehe ich drüber
trotz aller Rückschläge versuchte
erfahrene grüne die Liberalen inhaltlich
zu überzeugen sag mal du Rene ihr
fordert heute aber bitte nicht schon
wieder neue Autobahn ne davon steht
nichts im Koalitionsvertrag
keine Ahnung nie gelesen den Scheiß
ja danke
[Gelächter]
langsam lustig
ja hallo eine Kette von Demütigungen zum
Glück findet klempnow genug Rückhalt in
der Familie den ganzen Tag machen die
mich fertig es ist langsam echt keinen
Spaß mehr ich überlege wirklich
ernsthaft das ganze
hörst du mir überhaupt zu Hase
wie war es auf der Demo alles gut gar
nicht das Gute klimaschwein ich hasse
dich du bist schlimmer als Hitler
schlaf schön
möchte vielleicht noch was von dem
Porree Auflauf machen
die Grünen man möchte nicht mit ihnen
tauschen
Martin
so meine Damen und Herren
und dann ist da in der Ampel natürlich
noch der große paritätskandal im
Kabinett sitzen jetzt gegen alle
Versprechungen doch wieder mehr Männer
als Frauen nach dem Motto ist wirklich
ernst wird kannst du fürs
Verteidigungsministerium ja keine Frauen
nehmen sorry aber geht ja nicht ne
trotzdem bleibt der Kanzler überzeugter
feminist und wie er selber sagt und er
gendert fleißig nur halt auf seiner Art
aber auch zur Unterstützung der Bürger
und Bürger bei der Umstellung neben den
Hausärzten im Hausärzten und der Bürger
und Bürger das Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer sich zusammentun heute hat
das Treffen stattgefunden der
Finanzminister und Finanzminister und
der Gesundheitsminister und
Gesundheitsminister
hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf Gefällt
mir drückt und den Kanal abonniert zeige
ich euch meinen lautesten Schrei für das
menschliche Gehör ist der zwar nicht
wahrzunehmen aber ich würde eure Hunde
kurz rausbringen okay fertig